[Musique]
débat
[Applaudissements]
ils m'ont aidé
[Musique]
là
moi
et ça l'est aussi
[Musique]
mouais
et
[Musique]
savamment
m
là
[Musique]
et elles m'ont
l'aprilia
[Musique]
qui est il
ito
[Musique]
quel sens
jamais
calme
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pénitencier bientôt je sais pas chanter
mon seul
fermé et c'est là
que je finirais
ma vie comme d'autres gars l'ont fini
pour toi
ma mère
c'est ma
sonné saran
marié et après
je sais plus les
la rolls mais ça mais rien
ça m'a fait plaisir
[Musique]
je suis là
c'est magnifique
m
[Musique]
la mi temps
en
[Musique]
t
non
hu
et on va
je t'adore selon m
[Musique]
on ne sait pas
à
[Musique]
amd
et on
non
alors
c'était simple
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les
oui
je
[Musique]
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus